now on a scale of one to ten if you
stumbled upon this man in a dark
alleyway how much trouble do you think
you'd be in that's right a lot and when
he whips out that new world review
subscribe button you better believe you
are 100% going to hit it which will not
only appease the hulking mass that is
Benjamin but also provide you with
regular hunt onto content upload it
straight into your YouTube feed so huh
that's a bit of a net gain actually it's
kind of like being mugged and then
ending up with the wallet of the person
who robbed you hello and welcome to the
new world review your source for
everything anime and manga and today
we're diving into recent hunter hunter
in order to discuss the sub faction of
the succession war that we really
haven't gone into any form of detail
whatsoever which is the private army of
first Prince Benjamin and I believe that
this is going to be very very important
because it's quite tempting to think of
Benjamin as a one-man powerhouse going
into this contest but in reality his
greatest strength actually comes from
the supremely loyal organization backing
him and this very much spawns from
Benjamin's elected path in life as he is
a graduate of the cockin empires Royal
Military Academy and while he was there
he formed incredibly strong bonds with
many of the individuals who would go on
to serve within his own private army
however what this shows is that Benjamin
has a very strict military mind able to
utilize a wide variety of offensive and
defensive maneuvers capitalizing not
just on his own abilities but upon that
of great in manpower and the only other
Prince I think who even comes close to
this sort of infrastructure is 9th
Prince Hulkenberg who carries with him a
legion of loyal followers but it's just
not quite the same because they aren't a
cohesive force bonded together by a
common experience whereas Benjamin and
his army all share a common language if
you will which is the language of war
and that advantage in communication is
what places his organisation above that
of any of the current cohorts of
bodyguards in my opinion and nowhere do
these bonds become more apparent than
when we examine Benjamin's an inability
being Benjamin baton which on its own is
entirely powerless but it becomes
exponentially stronger with the
abilities of others and yes I say others
because the incredible factor about
Benjamin's private army is that they for
the most part all appear to be
incredibly skilled and proficient end
users so it's kind of like commanding a
miniature hunter association but back to
Benjamin baton what this allows Benjamin
to do is inherit the nen abilities of
his soldiers in the event that they pass
away although there is a strict
condition to inheriting a nobility which
is that the soldier in question must
have attended and graduated cocoons
Royal Military Academy as well as be a
current member of Benjamin's private
army
satisfying both foes the ability of any
given soldier will be directly inherited
by Benjamin himself which is very scary
idea because there is also the potential
of this being an indication of
post-mortem nen thus making the
abilities even more powerful under
Benjamin's control but despite the fact
that we are currently unsure if Benjamin
has a maximum limit on the number of
hearts who he can inherit this once
again goes to emphasize that this
exercise is much less about him
personally then it is an effort from his
entire support group because even if
each and every single one of them were
to die fighting for Benjamin he would
then carry on their inherited will and
become quite possibly the most
formidable Prince within the war with a
slew of nen abilities at his disposal
comparable to that of the Phantom troop
leader croa Lucifer but to begin
examining the army itself let's delve
into those who have made the ultimate
sacrifice for Benjamin starting with
Musa who's best described as a typically
cold and calculative individual with a
lazy eye but musei has Argus had a very
functional ability known as secret
window which allowed him to craft three
l-shaped constructs designed for
gathering intelligence with each of the
three doing so via a different manner so
for example one can be attached to a
target which will then telepathically
inform musei of everything said and done
by that target well they're quite
notably only one but can be in existence
at any given time and while we have no
confirmation on what brand of Nan this
is it does appear to make use of a
mission to separate pure aura from its
user now unfortunately for MU say he
fell victim to the nobility of 2nd
prince camilla as after he successfully
killed her Camila's hearts who activated
and took his life to restore hers first
resulting in secret window being
inherited by Benjamin now next up we
have shikaku who has a very underrated
and quickly skipped over ability known
as cold sept which effectively allows
him to pull a bit of a crawler and
procure the hot suit of another nen user
to do so he needs to craft a rectangle
of aura that goes on to become a card
trapping the design and ability within
it what is currently unknown is if
shikaku is able to use the ability after
doing so or if the hot suit is simply
contained within the card and is thus
inaccessible to its original user sadly
though we never really had the time to
discover the intricacies of concept and
shikaku was killed by ninth Prince
hülkenberg whose own inability had the
distinction of being able to pierce any
defense including shikaku scar ducati
goodness but despite being dead shikaku
scopes remained relevant for a while
because the will of one of hülkenberg
supporters who Midori took over the
empty vessel but eventually he would
come to shoot himself in the head but in
any case chicago's concept was also
inherited by the illustrious Benjamin
which is a very alarming thought
actually and one that I haven't
considered in any of my other success
more analysis because the fact that he
could add the very least sealed and in
abilities of others under the right
conditions is certainly not to be
underestimated and for our final
deceased member we also have Vincent who
was probably best known to casual manga
readers as the guy with the nose now
Vincent is an incredibly cold individual
taking the first opportunity he could to
kill a maid of 14th prince whoa whoa and
very shortly after he got into a
conflict with Karaka bill and queen
whiter which well rather predictably
well it certainly did not work out for
Vincent and he was forced to take a
suicide pill in order to prevent the
extraction of any information regarding
Benjamin but Vincent also had a
handy-dandy nan ability at his disposal
which I guess couldn't save his life but
it is known as air blur which rather
unfortunately we know next to nothing
about due to it being stolen by crop oka
the fall Vincent could put it to use
however it did look like he was going to
implement it to damage or at least
deflect a bullet from bill so it would
seem like an emissive power may be
comparable to that of Xena's old ex or
blast and we may find out soon because
this is the third ability that we now
know to be in the possession of Benjamin
now with all of the said Benjamin does
still have plenty of living members of
his private army one of which is Captain
balsamico might and we should pay some
extra attention to him because he does
have grand control over the organization
and an incredible reservoir of knowledge
regarding nen which was proven with his
in-depth knowledge of the
first-come-first-serve phenomenon in
regards to manipulation while sama Co
was also the individual who determined
that Hulkenberg was granted his heart to
buy his nan beast and was also able to
translate his volume of aura into a
relatively accurate estimate of power of
the ninth prince
so balsamico is a pretty dangerous guy
in terms of purely strategic resources
although we don't know at this stage
what his own inability is if indeed he
has one at all which I imagine he most
certainly does
because his knowledge is just far too
advanced to him to not have developed at
least one hansu by now Gnomeo Sapphira
cough who was the next highest-ranking
soldier that we know of although his
knowledge of nen is significantly
inferior to that of his captain who has
stated that fury Cove is less
knowledgeable in the area than that of
the average hunter however he is still
exceptionally intelligent and can
identify different brands of Nan on site
as well as at the very least being
capable of using both friend and Ken but
fury Cove is probably most notable as
being one of two of Benjamin soldiers
sent to engage in crop ACCA's nen
training course despite the fact that he
is already allegedly a proficient and
user
and sadly justice with the captain we
have not seen fury Cove demonstrator
Honsou as of yet but next up let's
examine another member who does have an
ability being Rehan now this guy was
assigned to 8th Prince Ali Saleh and is
ultimately responsible for Sallisaw his
death as Rehan was able to dispose of
the 8th Prince's nan beast through his
predator Honsou now predator works by
having Rehan select a target and has him
conjure a predator within the target
with the general idea that the more
information that Rehan gathers about the
targets ability the more effective the
predator will be when it is eventually
activated so with this in mind once
Rehan was able to dissect the abilities
of Sallisaw as nine beasts the predator
was conjured and it disposed of the nen
beasts leaving solace Allah completely
powerless to any form of attack which
would swiftly result in his death
predator does come with a lot of issues
though as it is completely defenseless
against other nen attacks so it relies
very much on stealth and very variable
timed use and furthermore after a
successful usage of predator Rehan is
unable to access any nin whatsoever for
48 hours so it is a very specific
utility technique now as for the one who
was actually responsible for killing
Silas Ali well that honor fell to you so
she whose nan ability is literally
called how to get away with murder which
much like predator involves him
selecting a target and stinging them
with an insect type thing go and after a
certain incubation period that will kill
the target this does of course also come
with its drawbacks though as if the
target moves more than 20 meters away
from you so she and the ability is
terminated not just put on hold like
advantages completely and this power can
only be used once upon any individual
victim meaning that you had better get
it right the first time it would seem
like this is quite an advanced heart so
though making use of elements of
conjuration manipulation and omission
which does make you so she not to be
quite an accomplished nan wielder and as
for our final member of relevance at the
moment I present to you Bobby miner who
doesn't seem to be as cold or blood
lusty as other members of the army and
is a much more quiet and reserved guy in
general he is of course another of the
soldiers who was sent to one to take
crop because nan training despite the
fact that yes he is already an end user
and what we don't know what his ability
is we do have a teeny tiny morsel of
information regarding it in that its
primary purpose is counteractive and
counteractive is a term that essentially
dictates that this is an ability that
springs into effect in response to an
action made by an opponent so if we were
to put counteractive abilities in to say
yugioh terms then they would be the trap
cards of the nan world and Camila's
hearts who was a great example of
corrective ability which activates only
once she has been killed
so Bobby minor has an ability along
these lines although I highly doubt that
it is anywhere near as powerful as
Camila's and look we're going to leave
it there because yes there are a bunch
of other named members of Benjamin's
private army but they really have not
done anything of substance in the story
yet and I feel like bombarding you all
with names is well it's a bit of a
pointless exercise in conclusion though
Benjamin's faction is the most organized
and powerful of any of the princes
forces that we have seen thus far in the
succession war taking Benjamin down
means destroying this entire army there
is no individual at play here both the
first prince and his loyal followers
should be considered one existence and
through the heart - that is Benjamin
baton that existence may quite literally
one day come to fruition but that pretty
much does it for this breakdown of
Benjamin's private army if you enjoyed
this video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the new ultra view
patreon because the support of all of
your amazing people is what continues to
make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video like share or
subscribe because it also helps for this
channel and incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun out anytime
and please do head over to my disco
server where a wide array of dining area
takes place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with your thoughts on
Benjamin's army this has been the New
World review and I'll see you next time
have you ever watched beyblade at any
point or at least in any of the series
generation so the short answer here is
no beyblade came out at a bit of a bad
time for me
because it was off to the era of
Dragonball and by that point I was like
a mopey teenager who just wanted to
explore you know the darker side of life
you know more adult-themed programming
that transferred over into my anime
interests and the age of stuff like
Evangelion Trigon faiths day night and
other shows and all of that began to me
meanwhile beyblade was airing
concurrently with these but every time I
saw an ad for it
I had my typical teenage thoughts of
disgust and how childish should have
looked which is funny enough because
that was my first impression of one
piece as well which is now my all-time
favorite series the manga that is not
the anime but it goes to show that you
can never exactly judge a series by its
initial appearance but when beyblade was
most relevant well that's exactly what I
did